a cidade o que passa na nossa cabeça
quando a gente ouve essa palavra
a maioria de nós aqui vive um grande
centro em uma grande cidade
então sabe bem as complexidades e os
desafios de viver no local assim a minha
fala hoje busca trazer algumas reflexões
sobre sobre outras possibilidades de
viver nas cidades faz o que fazem com
que esse ambiente possa ser mais
harmônico mais saudável mais equilibrado
e que a gente possa trazer
transformações positivas para eles
porque será que as cidades são locais
tão problemáticos os problemas
característicos das grandes cidades
eles são conseqüência de uma crise
socioambiental que está acontecendo no
mundo todo são causa e consequência
dessa crise
essas questões sempre mexeu muito comigo
e foi por isso que durante a faculdade
de biologia e resolvi estudar
restauração ecológica me aprofundar as
minhas pesquisas estudos nessa área da
estação ecológica um campo da ecologia
que busca a restauração de ecossistemas
degradados tentando recompor suas
funções e processos ainda na faculdade
eu conheci uma outra ciência bem menos
convencional
a permacultura isso não se deu através
das disciplinas mas através da conversa
com amigos
outros estudantes apesar de hoje em dia
na universidade federal de santa
catarina já existir um núcleo de
permacultura institucionalizado que
oferece uma disciplina de introdução à
permacultura para diversos cursos
vocês devem estar imaginando o que é
essa tal de permacultura
acredito que alguns já conheçam outros
ainda não ter uma cultura uma ciência
holística ou seja que abrange várias
áreas do
nesse momento o termo pode ser entendido
também como cultura permanente
esse termo foi criado na década de 70
por dois australianos bill mollison e
david romo green
esse foi um momento em que as pessoas e
os estudiosos começaram a perceber que a
crise socioambiental ela não era mais
característica de determinados pontos
ela estava acontecendo no mundo todo e
ela também era interligada nas dimensões
ambiental social e econômica
mas eu não vou ficar aqui falando muito
das causas dessa crise
a permacultura é embasada por três
princípios éticos que são eles cuidar da
terra cuidar das pessoas e compartilhar
os excedentes junto com outros
princípios técnicos
eles nos orientam a agir sobre alguns
sete pontos principais na sociedade para
conseguir transformar essa cidade essa
conseguir transformar a sociedade uma
sociedade mais harmônica ou sustentável
esses sete pontos formam a flor da
permacultura é um símbolo bastante
conhecido no meio em que cada uma das
pétalas da flor é um desses pontos chave
para a transformação são eles saúde e
bem estar físico e espiritual economia e
finanças posse da terra e comunidade
manejo da natureza espaço construído
ferramentas e tecnologia e cultura e
educação see site principais pontos
quando eu comecei a me aproximar mais da
permacultura e aprofundar meus estudos
na permacultura
eu estava decidido a sair dos grandes
centros não afastar dos grandes centros
sair do rio de janeiro e para algum
lugar do sul do país mais tranqüilo em
eu estava terminando o mestrado não
queria mandar o doutorado não tinha um
bom emprego à vista então achei que era
o momento ideal para começar essa minha
caminhada
decide então ir para santa catarina
conhecer um pouco mais
do estado e fazer o curso de formação em
permacultura
o pdc obedecer a sigla em inglês de
curso de design e permacultura
ele é um curso realizado dura mais ou
menos dez dias é realizado numa imersão
então todos os participantes ficam ali
dormindo e acordando juntos
compartilhando diversas atividades do
cotidiano
foi uma experiência maravilhosa na minha
vida e muito revolucionária pra mim com
a permacultura eu tive duas primeiras
grandes revelações
a primeira delas foi que nós podemos e
devemos perceber o mundo de outras
formas além da visão que é o nosso
sentido que em geral a gente mais
enfatiza
nós muitas vezes deixamos de lado os
outros sentidos como a audição olfato o
tato no momento em que a gente consegue
reduzir a velocidade e perceber mais
esses outros sentidos
a gente começa a ter uma percepção muito
mais sensível
vamos além desses cinco sentidos algumas
percepções mais sutis até uma outra
revelação que eu tive com a permacultura
foi que nós devemos e podemos ouvir o
que está dentro da gente
o nosso tem nosso interior a nossa
intuição então durante o curso de
permacultura eu tive uma intuição muito
forte que eu não deveria sair do rio de
janeiro deveria ficar e tentar
direcionar minha energia para melhorar
as coisas por aqui e seguir isso depois
que eu voltei eu recebi o convite para
dar aula de biologia numa escola aceitar
esse convite
durante o primeiro ano de que eu dava
aula no ano que eu dei aula eu criei um
grupo de um coletivo de permacultura
junto com alguns alunos e alunas e
alguns amigos que já estavam envolvidos
um detalhe importante é que
o rio de janeiro onde eu nasci e passei
a maior parte da minha vida e já tem
alguns anos que eu estou de volta nele é
um rio de janeiro que não é um dos
cartões postais do rio de janeiro que
está nas costas do cristo redentor na
zona oeste da cidade
a zona oeste da cidade do rio de janeiro
assim como diversas outras periferias
ela está enquadrada no que a gente chama
de desertos alimentares
esse é um conceito que caracteriza
regiões em que o acesso à alimentação
saudável de qualidade é muito difícil
normalmente a gente tem acesso à
esquerda na foto alimentos
industrializados ultra processados e
quando temos acesso a alimentos frescos
normalmente são cheios de agrotóxico
então vai além do alto preço dos
orgânicos é uma questão que você não
encontra lá pra comprar já que a gente
vivia e vive num local com diversas
dificuldades como a pouca atuação do
poder público local onde as árvores
estão cada vez mais escassas local onde
é difícil encontrar comida de qualidade
alimentos de qualidade muito motivados
pela pela cultura nesse coletivo
nós resolvemos agir pensar porque a
gente não pode fazer alguma coisa para
mudar isso está envolta da gente
resolvemos então criar uma agora flagrou
floresta em uma praça uma praça pública
numa áreas utilizadas na praça que era
totalmente aberta sem cercas ou muros
nada
muitas pessoas perguntaram na época mas
vocês vão plantar na praça será que as
pessoas não vão quebrar as mudas bom não
dava para saber a gente resolveu tentar
então começamos convidamos alguns
conhecidos
juntamos as ferramentas que cada um
tinha conseguimos algumas mudas e
sementes
criamos um evento no facebook e fizemos
o primeiro mutirão
foi uma experiência fantástica foram
mais de 30 pessoas
nem a gente acreditou que seria tão
positivo é tão legal como foi
só que depois disso as dificuldades
apareceram um pouco mais desse número
expressivo de pessoas
poucas pessoas continuarão cuidando do
espaço mais quatro ou cinco no máximo
permanecerão ali com freqüência cuidando
cuidando das plantas enfim plantar no
meio da cidade é muito difícil também
porque a gente não tem alguns recursos
básicos para o plantio
a gente não tem matéria seca para cobrir
o solo então em diversos momentos nós
tivemos que pegar galhos folhas secas
trazer de outros locais para colocar nos
canteiros
teve uma vez em que eu amigo conseguimos
a para de grama de uma escola do bairro
vizinho tava colocado em sacos de lixo e
esse destinada para o lixo
nós pegamos esse saco em chamas o carro
até o teto tentamos banco de trás chamas
do carro até o teto de palha
fizemos duas viagens e pela primeira vez
a gente conseguiu ter os canteiros do
jeito que a gente queria
os canteiros totalmente coberto de palha
com uma matéria seca é legal passar uns
três ou quatro dias a gente voltar lá
quando agente retornou à companhia de
limpeza urbana tinha varrido todos os
canteiros tiraram toda a palha
certamente eles não fizeram isso por mal
acredita que eles tenham imaginado que
aquilo ali era sujeira era lixo não sei
e tiveram muito trabalho para tirar
aquilo bom
além dessas dificuldades que eu citei
algumas tiveram muitas coisas positivas
na floresta já fazem quase dois anos que
ela existe
nós temos diversas árvores frutíferas
árvores nativas espécies medicinais
espécies agrícolas num espaço de
aproximadamente 400 metros quadrados
totalmente aberto uma agrofloresta
coletiva como está dizendo aquela
plaquinha ele
essa água floresta numa praça ela trouxe
muito mais do que plantas
ela criou e fortaleceu as relações
humanas diversas amizades surgiram ali
entre pessoas que já freqüentavam a
praça entre moradores do entorno da
praça
pessoas que começaram a freqüentar a
praça por causa da agrofloresta e essa é
a função das praças as praças
originalmente são locais de encontro
locais de troca de interação só que como
muitas praças na nossa cidade nos
grandes centros estão abandonadas
elas vão se tornando praças vazias uma
agrofloresta que surge uma praça
ela recupera essas interações humanas
uma agrofloresta que surge numa praça
ela restaura a nossa conexão com a
natureza ela aproxima de nós dentro da
cidade elementos naturais e nos relembra
que somos integrantes da natureza coisa
que a gente esquece muitas vezes uma
agrofloresta uma praça faz com que a
gente perceba os ciclos das plantas os
ciclos da natureza os ciclos da lua os
outros animais que habitam a livre e
além de tudo isso é ainda produz comida
pensar em criar uma agrofloresta uma
praça e ter a perseverança de cuidar
dela
essa ação foi muito motivada pelos
princípios da permacultura por tudo que
a permacultura trás
então pra mim falar em permacultura seja
no campo como é mais conhecida ou nos
grandes centros urbanos é falar em
revolução não uma revolução violenta com
o team enfrentamento com a polícia nada
disso
mais uma revolução criativa pacífica e
colaborativa que já está acontecendo em
várias partes do mundo não só aqui no
rio de janeiro e no brasil desde que eu
me aproximei da permacultura e tchau ela
faz parte da minha vida desde então
eu tive duas reflexões sobre dois pontos
que nós precisamos ter para conseguir
gerar transformações significativas na
sociedade
o primeiro deles os dois são muito
simples o primeiro deles é que nós
devemos mudar nosso padrão de pensamento
da competição para a cooperação a nossa
sociedade nos induz muito a competir
desde que desde quando nós somos
crianças nós somos estimulados a
competir competir na escola para ter as
melhores notas
precisamos competir no vestibular para
conseguir uma vaga na universidade
muitas vezes competimos no nosso
ambiente de trabalho para conseguir
destaque e de repente um cargo melhor o
melhor salário na ecologia a competição
também é muito destacado é dito que as
espécies competem entre si pra conseguir
obter recursos
isso faz sentido em muitos casos
realmente ocorre
só que tem um outro aspecto que não é
falado da cooperação e uma floresta por
exemplo uma semente de uma árvore
ela normalmente só germina e se
desenvolve bem debaixo da copa de outra
árvore
as árvores que possuem raízes profundas
elas retiram a água das regiões mais
profundas utilizam essa água mas também
disponibilizam a água para outras
árvores e outras plantas que têm raízes
superficiais numa floresta ainda as
árvores se conectam através de redes de
fungos que ligam as suas raízes e essas
conexões permitem a troca de informações
e de nutrientes
então a cooperação tá muito presente na
natureza
um outro ponto segundo ponto fundamental
é que nós devemos sair apenas do sonhar
então sonhar é fundamental mas a gente
tem que dar o passo seguinte que é
planejar para conseguir juntar as ações
e elementos necessários para então ir
pro outro passo
que ao realizar muitas pessoas têm
idéias maravilhosas mas elas não
conseguem dar esses dois passos planejar
e realizar e tem um quarto passo que é
fundamental e muita gente esquece que é
o celebrar celebrar significa reconhecer
a reconhecer a caminhada reconhecer
todos os avanços os avanços que você
conseguiu as conquistas as derrotas
os aprendizados reconhecer que tudo isso
que a gente fez nos dá força tão
celebrar nos dá energia para seguir para
então sonhar novamente planejar realizar
celebrar e sonhar muito obrigado
[Aplausos]